he used to be the best of friends we're
still the best of friends no you're not
who says we're not said somewhere else
you know if I've done something to you
just tell me what I've done here when
you didn't do Anthony I just don't like
you no more
liked me yesterday
[Music]
good to see you again
I'm so fabulous Brendan it is such a
pleasure to meet you I feel like I'm
eating dessert right now because the
chemistry between you guys is so
delicious and effortless and I know
um you know the last film this is the
first film you're in together since 2008
In Bruges and I first wanted to know
what have you learned from each other
after all this time oh Jesus ongoing I
think there's always uh We've we find
like we're very different in loads of
ways and there's a kind of a common well
it's a kind of a soul kinship that
allows us to discover it's funny that
all the different things from our very
different lives which are you know not
that different but different enough we
were different generationally we've you
know we're living in different places so
coming around it's always we don't
really hook up all that what should we
don't like once every couple of years it
doesn't matter it always feels as if we
just continue where we left off but it's
kind of like in terms of learning
anything I'm not sure we just we just
yeah we find things out every day really
yeah
exactly what he said no it is not it's
you know yeah I don't know I mean I have
an awful grow love for this man you know
and I I do know in in ways that I
I'm not too shy to articulate but I
don't have the words I don't have the
exact Precision to understand how he's
informed of my life but I do know as an
actor as a most importantly there was a
man as a human being which puts into
friend Father all those ways he's a huge
huge influence on me
um and I just have the height of respect
for him yeah he's just one of the greats
you know as a human being an actor yeah
all that jazz it's brilliant stuff but I
adore the man and enough so that like
once every three years is enough of a
measure yeah yeah you know what I mean
we don't we don't we don't see each
other that much but there's people I see
on the regular in my life that I don't
feel as clearly as I feel him when I get
to spend time with him so all that's
there you know it's a kind of an odd one
because like every time we meet up
there's love on their own I'm mad about
this for that as well he's a absolute
gentleman like and it's it's a lot of
fun and it's one of those things that
funny enough with all the talk about
neediness there's no neediness in the
relationship so it doesn't matter we win
there's never any kind of thing I mean
we said when we're leaving this time
because I don't really I don't care when
we see each other next time like because
you know it's just there yeah it's just
that you know it's like knowing that
some people are out in the world is
enough sometimes yeah yeah and it's just
so organic and I can tell just with you
guys talking to each other that
resonance and you're both shy Irish Boys
by the way that SMS
so funny but I gotta tell you guys this
is my favorite film you've done together
it's my favorite Martin McDonough film I
feel like we've seen romantic breakups
explored so much and I actually run a
support group for people that are
heartbroken and more more people come to
meetings for friendship heartbreaks
because they're still right wow that's
crazy to me how often or how it really
and people become because of the
dissolution of friendships they've lost
their lifelong friends right because
it's not like you get this phone call
that you're like Hey we're not friends
anywhere but in this movie you do which
I think is so beautiful and so Colin I
know Martin's favorite part of the film
is actually the expression that Parikh
makes when comb tells him I don't want
to be friends anymore and I wanted to
know what went into making that face and
what did you imagine Tarik was thinking
about in that moment I was just thinking
of what she was saying and I I put but
friendship is more nebulous than how
it's presented you know you don't have
to have to have a couple of days so you
don't share a bed with each other you're
not working towards maybe a marriage or
cohabitation or having kids like it's
more nebulous and so if there is a
dissolution Sometimes some of those
people that come and visit your support
group are they left hanging that they
don't exactly know where they stand yes
and that's why I think this film is so
beautiful and Martin
he lets me know where I stand crushing I
mean there's so much of so much of
parik's life is built around the
presence of this man in his everyday and
so it's it's yeah it's it's just
crushing it's a core part of how you see
yourself too people that you have kind
of settled into knowing well that's
stable that's that's a reality that's
just a Continuum that's you know that
kind of a connection like that is is a
Continuum and therefore this allows me
to be myself at a particular you know
from a particular place of safety but
I'm so and I'm somewhere between being
an individualist and you know a a fan of
the communal as well and those are two
juxtapositions that we're always
bouncing between you know a need for
Solitude and I need to be part of
something greater than ourselves so I I
think oftentimes friendship gives our
lives worth I mean we have to get it you
have to find worth within yourself again
I'm interested but um but you also we do
get work and I think it's justifiable
and I think it's beautiful I think it's
understandable that we get worth from
those people that we choose consciously
and choose through shared experience to
continue to have in our lives and hope
that they continue to invite us into
their lives and there's another thing
about where you know Colin's character
has lost parents and never really you
know his his whole he he has culted it
by
um you know his nature and been being
feeling in some way opting not to deal
it always felt in part of that
expression you were talking about
there's the whole weight of that grief
suddenly yeah that whole revisitation of
that kind of Abandonment and what was
going on there yeah that that was uh it
was doubled up on a little bit there was
no place to grieve I mean I know I don't
think his town Tales there to school
like oh my well my dad's mum died she
and he was 13. there was no room for
crying there was one day have your tears
and then we're moving on so there would
have been a bit of that and women women
were allowed to wear widow's weeds for a
year and would be expected to wear it
that you were in the morning the man had
to get on with it so there's you know
yeah both are a prison by the way
expected to be totally that's a yes and
you know different absolutely wow this
is like such a fascinating conversation
I wish I was in the same room with you
guys but it is true I feel like that's
also why this film is so beautiful
because we get to see that emotion from
men a man hurting saying hey I want to
be your friend we never people never say
that out loud there's like this shame
around that and even you know Brendan I
wanted to ask you about calm because the
reason why he wants to end the
Friendship is because he wants to devote
his time to being this true artist and I
read that you said there's a sentiment I
feel like we have as humans where we you
feel like we have to be prepared to
suffer for our art and the three of us
are in the entertainment industry and so
I feel like we're constantly at that
intersection and so I wanted to know
what your thoughts are on that like is
is Art more important than friendship I
I it's funny I I was talking to my son
about this yesterday and about the need
for like people like who've gone into
um say you go into a play and you get
into his place that's so dark I was
talking to somebody who'd gone into a
play who spent eight months being in a
very very dark place and and they took
about seven years to get over it really
because there's a there's a kind of a
there's a soul memory where if you go
into those places for long enough
um it can actually take your life away
and start bleeding into your life so the
interaction between arts and living is
always a consistent one for me uh
I I think that that that living is such
a gift that you have to treasure it uh
equally with with art and that you can
sacrifice all you want but if it's
fundamentally stopping you living and
and and enjoying the living of your life
uh you're paying to a higher price for
it so IL fosu Freer all that stuff about
it's necessary to suffer uh I think that
can be true it doesn't have to be true
and shouldn't be worn as a kind of badge
of honor but if you have to go there you
go there but if what you're if by going
there you are ruining the greatest gift
you're given I think you're you're
you're you're besmirching it and it's
that's the way that's that's where I put
my balance if it's damaging me at some
point on a fundamental level I'm getting
out of there this is what happens in
this one it damages it damages him
including
obviously it damages you know party but
column or the price you pay price he
pays like when you say the despair is
coming when he says how's the despair
it's coming back a bit yeah that's
awesome yeah and even the time where he
sees that there is a certain point in
the film where he feels he's looking at
the the first consequence yeah yeah and
and there's a certain amount of saying I
did it I suffered from my art I was
prepared to go to the end and so he's
not seeing the perspective that Siobhan
has shortly but you but he's saying I'm
prepared to sacrifice all for art and
there is a beauty in that so I think the
film what's great about the film is it's
kind of tossing it all up in the air and
saying well you guys figured that I love
it it's so hard though Brendan because
we we do wear busyness as a badge of
honor in life and I'm sure with you guys
are actors so you spend so much of your
life being another person and away from
your friends and family so I I commend
you and I can't thank you enough for
making this movie and and putting the
art into the world because it's amazing
before I leave really quick Colin um the
last time you and I spoke was for the
Batman and Brandon remember in studio
that day yeah you're gonna be in the
Joker sequel Brendan with Joaquin
Phoenix and Lady Gaga and I was
wondering if you guys have had a chance
to exchange advice or talk about Jokers
or Batman no but we're going to be
working off the philosophy of two
degrees of separation from now on we've
decided yeah no we haven't he won't tell
me nothing about it sworn to secrecy
very admirable yeah and I know nothing
about mine except I read the first
episode and it's the the penguin thing
and it's magic it's so tasty well he was
brilliant in the Penguin and Joaquin as
Joker is indelible in my head so this is
such a privilege to go into that level
of work it's fantastic I can't wait what
does he not want to be friends with you
anymore
what is he 12. what the hell is going on
with you me brother he's Donald
I'm a major fan of your work and I know
you're actually a major fan of the
director Martin mcdonough's work so much
so that you actually had a picture of
him on the background of your phone I
did even working with him isn't it crazy
how that happened
um it's not crazy it's just weird
no honestly I did I'm a big believer and
you know attract them what you you put
out there and and that and you know Mark
was on the list of directors I wanted to
work with and I went as far as putting
them on the front of my phone as a
screensaver
and literally up and to the point where
I met him in New York to discuss the
film she was on my phone and I was it
was when I was waiting on him to come in
I was like I should get this off okay so
I put my phone down and he sees his face
pop up he'll just think I'm insane and
whatever and but yeah that was there I
think it worked I think it worked
absolutely I mean you retracted it it's
so insane but now that you've been in a
Martin McDonough film did it like
surpass your wildest dreams and what did
you learn about Martin's process working
on this movie
um you know just being kind of
out there and on on
um in aqua Island and that was it was
just a little magical experience to be
honest and
it's it it does feel like the most Irish
film ever and and to be part of that and
be part of my McDonalds kind of you know
circle is really nice as well
um being a massive fan of his and
I'm Brandon I'm Colin and Kerry and and
all of that and
you know and getting to kind of
you know
experiment in that and that world and
play a character and bring it to life is
um yeah I feel really grateful ah I
can't wait for people to see you in this
let's talk about your character Dominic
because he he's a character that I feel
like has a clearer grasp on the truth
than everybody else on the island and I
was wondering how you connected to
Dominic and what it is you love about
Dominic
I think it shows honesty
um as you said there are truth isn't it
I mean he sees it for what it is and
that filter of you know not saying
something to protect someone's feelings
is kind of gone from eliminated it's
almost like he just says it and you kind
of get the harsh truth and it's probably
the best advice you get as well
um and it's almost like kids you know
when kids say something to you they
don't have that
thing of I may hurt your feelings by
telling you this but they just say it
they see it for what it is and say it
for what it is so I think there's a bit
of that there but there obviously is he
does see stuff in a different uh at a
different angle I think and
you know I just wanted to plan that that
essence of living day to day and
tomorrow's a new day kind of attitude
because he is he's that little kind of
force of positivity in that for Colin
well for pork
I love that example you gave of kids
because that that is I guess that must
have been a point of inspiration for you
because that is exactly what it's like
and it's probably really uh relieving to
be able to see honesty in that way right
like there's just heaviness to it it's
like well
yeah you get to a certain age and you do
that and people don't like it so you
kind of only do up until like a certain
age I wonder what cut off that is I
wonder what I said
that's so funny
um what I found most mesmerizing to
watch about your performance uh Barry
was the way that you moved in Dominic
and I was wondering I wanted to ask you
about the physicality you brought to him
and how you came yeah yeah me and Martin
had many discussions of you know kind of
you know character traits and mannerisms
and
I just wanted to be that kind of uh you
know all right up and going into a new
kind of that's not working let's go
there and that kind of I wanted to
inject that into this kind of movement
and
and
yeah just kind of like a little twitch
of some sort
um so yeah we did we had many
discussions and we had to find the
balance and
you know and humanize them as well and
not make it anyway other than you know
truth truthful yeah you can tell and and
it really you just really brought it to
life on screen I love it I was also
reading that you lived with your co-star
Colin Farrell yeah no cool and I was
wondering if how what was it like having
Colin as your roommate and did he did
living with him help you at all with
your character yeah I did yeah I did
because that relationship still exists
you know and Dominic and Colin uh
Dominic and pork and me and Colin it's
kind of similar relationship you know
and only I don't tell Colin off and be
like you know
put it it did help you know every
Everything does help and being on that
island as well you know it's so small
and you know you know everyone and it
just you couldn't stay within that
bubble
and and I couldn't have that aura as
well which is which is you know time
doesn't exist or you don't know what you
know
you know Tom of the year it is or well
you do know what time of the year is but
you don't know what kind of year is
um but yeah it did did help massively
yeah I was reading too that you were
looking for cell phone service on the
island when you weren't shooting on the
edge of the cliff literally like you
know I think it's over there and um what
I love about seeing you and Colin
together in this movie because you were
saying this is like one of the most
Irish films ever which is the best part
of it but this is actually your third
film with Colin the last one was the
Batman but you guys didn't yeah scenes
together I was wondering what impresses
you most about Colin Farrell I think
Colin is an amazing actor you know and
and we get to see in this as well you
know he's so
you know he really lets himself get
vulnerable and and you know has the
comedy as well and he goes through
everything in this movie I remember
actually seeing it and being like you
know texting and saying I think this is
one of your best performances ever man
you know I'm really really proud and you
know I I really mean that and so just as
a younger actor watching him I'm always
learning but you know he's a role model
to me as well to be honest and he's
always been there for me and
you know just as a as a human being and
you know I get to to learn and watch as
well from him that's beautiful I hope we
get to see you two and in future movies
together
have you guys talked about like penguin
meeting Joker and a future Batman film
oh yeah
um
no
we haven't
say anything but no one believes me eh
anyways